Moscow over the past decade the Czar's
gilded churches and monuments to the
proletariat have given way to the
symbols of modern Russia opulent
capitalist towers that poke through the
clouds at the heart of this is where I
met Dimitri Grisham hello it's a real
tree he's the co-founder of mail route
group and one of only a few people east
of Helsinki who can drive me to the
office in his own Tesla I organized the
drive for all my place like three
thousand people because they want all it
sets out to the right
Dimitri sits atop a Russian tech empire
and runs an investment fund for robotics
with its roots in Silicon Valley that
doesn't make you want to move there you
have so much going on here
maybe one day Never Say Never right
overall then do you consider the Russian
taxi in competitive yes and and you know
it's interesting things that it's very
few countries where local players are
very strong and compare it for example
this China's as Internet's fully closed
we have a Facebook Instagram all kind of
Western players and still pretty
successful so I think we have pretty
pretty pretty tough competition
why are Russian engineers so good I
think it's type of education in Russia
still like mathematics in any secret
engineering to give you very broad broad
of view so if you want to be very
creative in in technologies I think very
good education
this is a guy a charging station here
okay so everybody knows when you're in
the office yeah
[Music]
Dmitry's tried to copy Silicon Valley
culture here in Moscow where malroux
group operates to instant messaging
networks a search engine a price
comparison website and a ton of online
games they also control the three
largest Russian social networking sites
the biggest one is VK the facebook.com
Dmitry and mail route group took over VK
in 2014 after its founder Pavel Durov
refused to reveal information about
ukrainian activists to the criminal
zhirov lost his company and now lives in
self-imposed exile Dimitri's also what
are the world's biggest investors in
robotics he put a hundred billion
dollars into American firms that produce
some familiar faces what's been the
biggest hit of all your robotics company
saw I like all my investments I can say
definitely
I like bb-8 a lot also zip line for the
drones long current delivery and now
they start to do blood the Rivoli rwanda
[Music]
Demitri ships all kinds of guard gear to
Moscow to try it out see if he wants to
invest what's the point in the game we
should kill robots so good for you as
someone who puts all this money into
robots are you oh it's really cool to
get a taste of the high life of a
technology Dmitri and I headed for a
bite to eat at the tallest restaurant in
Europe 354 meters above the Moscow
traffic tell me a little bit about your
family history so well yeah I have
pretty pretty much engineering family
and I was born in c2 called Kapusta vr1
caboose ter was the Soviet Union's
answer to area 51 a top-secret city
where rocket scientists like Dimitri's
grandfather tested ballistic missiles
and rockets during the space race
Dimitri grew up programming our
computers that plugged into Soviet TVs
but things really took off when he
enrolled at Moscow State Technical
University in 1995 in the same year a
Microsoft announced Windows 95 this
famous song from Rolling Stone stood me
up
next two years I tried to write my own
Windows it's so expensive windows maybe
I can just like write it
cheap cheap restaurant sitting could
write in it but after sometimes I say uh
okay now it's too hard
he might have failed to rewrite the
world's most popular operating system
but he did stumble on the copycat
business model the became mail route
group and at the height of the 2001 tech
crash he had to find a way to keep the
new company alive with no cash I became
like CEO of the company and my deal was
look let's try to survive no matter how
we tried to do a lot of tricks for
example by coming with my car it was a
Lada Russian Russian car we put several
servers like physically and moves them
to more cheaper data center it's hard to
imagine now but in 2004 only 9% of
Russians had internet access
what was the Russian government's
assessment of the technology industry
they didn't know that they exist that
all changed in 2012 Russia had become
the biggest internet market in Europe
some people use the web to complain
about Putin
and organized protests against his
re-election the Kremlin responded in
full Orwellian glory with a series of
laws that allows them to flag opposition
sites as extremists and blacklist them
ever since it's been hard to tell where
the Vlad web begins and ends I think in
the US the idea is that the Russian
government and the tech companies are
just intertwined and that if the
government wants to read people's emails
whatever they want to do they're gonna
let them do that if you follow the law
your key definitely the laws became more
complicated right and sometimes it's
definitely the way how to interpretate
the law if you have right now laws that
government can shut down any service
which is not hosting the service inside
of Russia as I can this is law
definitely you can have big discussion
as low as good or bad but this only way
how to appear you can operate those new
laws passed this year would make Edward
Snowden weep into his bush the demand
all cites Russians can access move their
servers here including the googles and
Facebooks of the world what's on Russian
soil they have to store six months worth
of data about people's every move online
and then give the Kremlin access Russian
companies like mailroom protested they
said these measures would take a
ridiculous amount of storage space but
they obviously lost American companies
have said there's no way they're moving
to Russia
so now their criminal enterprises here
and that's how you build a sovereign
Internet when we grow our business how
concept was that internet was a very
global system no border at all use it
everywhere can connect to everywhere
data can be migrated everything so it's
really verbal phenomena but now I think
that fundamental global shift everywhere
that you have country you have borders
and inside this borders you have
different kind of rules how data is
moving how connectivity is moving who
can connect to what who can do what so
excited we're not having like global
internet we're having some kind of some
global internet but a lot of like local
internet and for me this is big set into
the jump so so change just a couple of
weeks after we visited Demetri he
stepped down as CEO mailroom the
government-approved CEO VK is taking his
place the new guy also happens to be the
son of the head of Russia's largest
state-run television channel
you
[Music]
[Music]